Democrats are pushing a radical three
trillion dollars team that includes
taxpayer bailouts for Union run pensions
money to illegal immigrants which will
do nothing to help this nation combat
Cove in nineteen this is not a relief
package its speaker Pelosi's partisan
1,800 pays socialist shopping list we
should defeat it i expired gentleman
yields gentleman from oklahoma reserves
gentlewoman from New York is recognized
mr. speaker I'm very pleased to yield
one minute to the dynamic hard-working
committed gentlewoman from Connecticut
the distinguished chair of the
Subcommittee on labor Health Human
Services and education Ms DeLauro
gentleman from Connecticut is recognized
for one minute
the heroes Act is a critical three
trillion dollar rescue for our frontline
workers cities and states are small
businesses and it creates the kind of
modern-day safety net I have been
fighting for with so many brave allies
in and outside the US Congress paid sick
days paid family and medical leave is
now available to all workers including
those workers in warehouses health care
grocery stores pharmacies and retail the
child tax credit is now available for
all families raised to $3,000 per child
over six years old and a higher benefit
for younger children cutting child
poverty nearly in half we raise the
maximum food stamp benefit by fifteen
percent bigger than in 2009 and we
purged president Trump's 135 billion
dollar gift to real estate developers
and hedge fund managers I urge my
colleagues let us act boldly and let us
act swiftly for this nation I yield back
gentleman yields gemma woman from New
York reserves gentleman from Oklahoma is
recognized Thank You mr. speaker mr.
Speaker I yield one minute to my very
good friend the distinguished Republican
ranking member of the Judiciary
Committee mr. Jordan of Ohio gentleman
from Ohio is recognized for one minute
I think the gentleman for yielding mr.
speaker in one week
Democrats have shown us exactly what
they want to do in one week's time may
8th one week ago seven Democrats on the
coronavirus Select Committee sent a
letter to Universal stainless and alloy
products in western Pennsylvania and
they say give back your PPP money right
here's a letter you have not returned
these funds
three days later May 11th four of our
colleagues two Democrats two Republicans
send a letter to those seven Democrats
and say hey wait a minute
Universal stainless followed the rules
they're entitled to their money if they
have to give it back they will have to
layoff steel workers and today this bill
does what this bill does what it gives
tax dollars to illegal immigrants in one
week's time take money from steel
workers give it to illegal immigrants
that's the Democrat vision for their
country and if for no other reason
that's why we should vote against this
bill I yield back
gentleman yields gentleman from Oklahoma
reserves gentlewoman from New York is
recognized
gentlewoman from New York is recognized
how much mr. speaker I'm delighted to
yield to my friend the distinguished
chair of the subcommittee that does so
much good work here MS Kaptur gentleman
from Ohio is recognized for one minute
I'd like to thank chair loi for that
gracious set aside and wish to say that
the American people expect Congress to
have their backs our economy needs help
with historic levels of unemployment
bearing down and the heroes Act will
provide a bridge of support to save
lives and lively
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]